Hello everyone
, I'm Seiro Sora, Director of Final Fantasy VII Remake.
This time, I'm going to deliver it from the studio for the first time in a while.
Well, I think it's about time I'm getting tired of broadcasting from my room.
I'm renting a wider area that is a little different from the studio.
Everyone is thinking about social distance. I
'm proceeding while paying attention to infection prevention measures.
This is an introduction to the additional infighters who are in charge of this.
[Music] I
have
[Music]
n
I was introduced to Guy, but
since FINAL FANTASY 7, I will call it ff 7,
but the number of stars related to ff 7 has increased.
I
don't have a hairstyle. I hope that the
fighter can make appropriate adjustments. Then
, I would like to go to the introduction of Sephiroth, which is the main subject.
So I think it's one of the most famous villains
. The legendary Soldier that appeared in ff 7
isn't a certain cell, but it causes strength beyond human knowledge.
Ultimately, it's the ultimate.  I will try to take the power of the stars to myself by using the destructive seriousness. The
feature is Masamune's
latest work ff 7 Remake is a work that you can enjoy a lot of stylish images and I
am looking forward to the continuation.
I sent it to Advent Children
.
No, it's ffac for Minecraft art. I think
this wide dynamic range is a
job that doesn't get boring. It's interesting.
Please note
that, as usual, the in-game camera is special
and under development
.
[Music]
Yes, this is Sephiroth in Bra now. The
biggest feature is that dogs are long.
Because the prefecture is long, the beach is wide anyway
and the ratio  It's a comparative tone. It's said that the opponent's attack is easy to hit because it's
tall.
Since it's Sephiroth, I'll keep the dark image, but
please think that 7 p 8 p can enjoy the final battle specification
.
It is regrettable when Sephiroth is in a pinch.
There are various effects when one wing is inserted.
First, the speed and attack power will increase a little
, and you will be able to make another aerial jump.
And above all, you will be able to get super well against smash attacks. Even if you
can overcome this one-sidedly,
it does not mean that you can prevent damage, so if you overuse it, for example, if you make
one mistake
[Music] It
may disappear if you shoot down the opponent
. Pinch is judged not by simply accumulating damage but by looking at the whole game from a bird's-eye view.
I finally got it. When the
stock number is inferior, I will
tell
you and the type will come out at about 30%. There is such a difference.
Then, I would like to introduce the basic technique, but before that, I
will talk about the sweet spot.
There are exceptions, but in the case of slashing, it is stronger than a little before the center of the investment trust.
For example, in the case of such a city,
it will be like this when slashing.
The
damage
is the strongest in the center of the slash, but the
war criminals are often careful about things like
skins.  It's a
school that comes out early, so let's use it after the opponent approaches.
Next, there is a good reach with the attack wing while stepping on the front of the dash attack
.
I think it's a technique
Next, sideways heavy attack As you
can see, the reach is quite long and you can hit it up and down,
for example Da  Even if you hit the opponent normally, it will not hit,
so it is a structure called a potted temple in such a case
.  You can also launch a sticking opponent.
Also, as usual, the tip is the strongest because it is a lunar act.
Next, I will shoot and move to the west of the clock today.
I don't know,
but it's a story that must be offset, but
next is a side smash attack with powerful full power justice.
There is enough reach, power, and blow-off,
but I like it quite a lot.
Next, I was taught a fairly wide range of upper smashing actions
. It also hits opponents before and after the ground. It's
so wide, but I like it because it's big, so be careful.
You can do it. The
power is also high. If you
don't hit the ground, debris will not come out, but it is possible to prevent the return.
The range is wide on purpose, isn't it?
I think it's the one that comes out early as a technique of Sephiros with a big moon
.
It can also be used to prevent return in this way by making use of the
length of the  And I think
that there is another feature
that you can pierce the attack wall in the microphone and jump. It is possible to
confirm how to use this,
such as using it as a feint.
It's an attack with a wider range than an attack, so it's
powerful, so it's possible to turn around and use the back air instead of the air
.
If you don't, you won't hit the enemy on the ground.
You can learn just barely on the ground even if you hit your head with a small jump
.
Specifically, the front aerial attack is a bombardment 13 frames
Behind the back student 15 It's a complaint
, but I can't say that because this game is
designed with a funny party game in mind.
I think it's okay to say the details only to those who participate in the tournament, so it's
fun to hit a single aerial attack. It's fun to hit a
back
aerial attack.
It's similar to the upper smash attack I mentioned earlier. Well, you can actually use it instead.
The attack range in front is not very wide, but it can be
used for various economies, so I think you should try it.
Next aerial attack This is a prison gate
It is a dive attack that is said to be a dive attack. As
usual, it can also be used for attacks from above the floor.
I think it's possible,
but there is a meteo, but it's a
little useless outside of the game. Will I self-destruct?
If you want to use your right hand, you should keep the scaffolding redefined and use it
.  A fighter with a sword has a good throwing power overall
.
This is also a reason
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll throw it back and report it.
Ueno Raise It will be connected to the combo immediately
[  Music]
And
although the power of throwing and throwing is low
, I think that it can be used for some combination, or it can be used for such things as breaking the guidance, so
please consider it
carefully.
The special move masters three projectiles depending on the stage of accumulation.If you
hit it almost without eating, the flare
distance is relatively long and it will explode at the end. If
you save a little,
the distance is shorter than that, but
the attack is outstanding.  And if you eat to the end,
Gigaflare will blow over and hit the opponent strongly.
Even flare will take a long time to fire, but the
power is enormous.
You can stop eating in the middle with the shield button, but on the
wall  I can't hold it.
I think Nishishinjo Ki Fure can't be used in the air.
Abe Time is too long, isn't it?
There is also such a usage for Gigaflare
[Music]
Smash I used to mix it.
There is also such a
usage. I can think of why it explodes in front of the pot right now, but it's
actually a little.  I will explain
later. It can be done after absorption,
but it does not make a big recovery amount. Why is it strong when it explodes? It
can also be
reflected. Reflection is recommended that the play is never reflected.
Is there a possibility that you will die instantly in 0 minutes?
I think that having three missiles is a considerable strength, so I hope you can
use them well
.
You can just hit a thin ball, but you can eat it, but it
doesn't look like there was such a big change. But this soul has a completely different concept.
And after a while, it will be guided and explode.
Depending on the degree of squeezing and overlapping
, the number of true numbers will increase or go around the opponent. Up to 5
It is possible to
seal.  It is also possible to raise and grab it.
You can also change the direction at the time of launch. It
may be possible to use it in this way
.
I think it's best to use it because it's advantageous to charge it no matter which way you fall. It
's possible to absorb it.
It's also possible to reflect it. Well, it may be a little difficult to use for an attack, but by the
way.
hiro It's also possible What happens when you
get tired It's kind of like you can pick up things around people
[Music] It's a
special
move.  You can hit it in any direction you like because it is in firefox etc. It
can be used to keep a distance from the opponent and it can also be used
to score points
By the way, it was a line until now, but it is a miscalculation  If you keep doing it,
there is a technique of slashing 8 times, which is 8 throws and 1
battle.There is a sufficient shooting performance that is rare for such an urban type technique
.
But be careful because it can't be helped a little.
There is a slight difference in the flight distance.
This one battle
[Music] This one battle [Music]
This 8 throws one battle
Hattori line is a little longer, so if you really want to return, use 8 head
lines
Of course, it's originally intended to be used for return. The
village owner can catch the battle, but in the 8-throw battle, it jumps up a little
. There is also a way to attack using it.  However, please be careful about this difference. It is
called the next special move
first. It can be used like a counter with a move released from Honeycomb Shield in one year of major
.  As you can see,
it is invalid for attacks from behind
. Unfortunately, missiles cannot be reflected. It can be prevented, but it
is rare for a counter type
to break into a little attack.  The
maximum charge shot is also tough. It just prevents liquor damage.
It can also be used to prevent return.
Especially those who have aggressive planting technique should be careful.
The trump card is supernova. It's a very
difficult technique for a Japanese male from the West to cause a super-new star in Meteor and burst his work. Did you notice
that each person is taking different reactions here
?
[Music
]  I don't think it's going to happen, so I'll try to stop it on the verge, but
from the right one is blown away, one is a mushroom,
and one seems to
be doing a sea break.  The effect is now appearing
. It's a slow flower mushroom that is shaken by a projectile.
[Music]
I was worried about plastic.
The
damage to your skin will be great. You
can put it in the brewery normally. It will be even bigger.
This is a mushroom. The record is scary.
This is also a technique that can be done from 0%
accumulated damage, etc.  By the
way, I
put it in the booth color ticket of the cloud today,
which is also a super cube Shin-style version
.
FINAL FANTASY VII ADVENT
TUB  Performance such as power is completely the same as odd color.
As you may know, there are sleeveless colors in the crowd color of the cloud
. Well, this is also familiar to the original fans.
No
Next  Introducing the stage I made a stage called the Great Cavity of the North
The shape of the stage itself was simplified, but the background is the king of the story.
This includes the development of the final stage of ff 7.
I
don't have it, so if you don't want to see this, you should turn right or
not. Who doesn't have to heal? It's a game 20 years ago.
It's not limited, so
I'd appreciate it if you could take a look. Well then, I'll come. The
final battle was fought in FINAL FANTASY VII. The
promised land and the end point of the union.
And in the distance, the second form of high wind that turned into a jet engine is
also flying.
Sephiroth activated the star Forobos Pro magic right hand.
The purpose of the party is to open up the party
.
[Music]
There was a step like this in the original,
but I jumped, but
the big cavity in the north was 2000 years ago.  It is said that Genova fell in the place where it was
sealed in the ancient spring and excavated in trust.
This area was also adopted in the stage of DISSIDIA FINAL FANTASY
, reminiscent of the place where Genova synthesis was fought.  Let
the basic floor also refer to the floor around here
And this is the sealed Holy
[Music]
Holy activates
and the party tries to escape Escape
and spread out in front of you
And Holy can pop out  Turns around to stop
The high wind is in the third form there here,
but it is said that Holy was activated too late, but
I can not stop my right hand
There, the life stream that is the power of the star springs up and adds  The
cruise stage may not have been a story like this before. I hope
you enjoy it.
Then, I would like to move on to the actual battle. This time,
I would like to win and fight in a brawl.  For some
reason,
you can enjoy Boss Rush. There are a lot of
bosses from
all over the world.
But of course it's tough,
so you have to be careful. At first, Rio Lens
Yeah, but it's a game to
make it.
Good filtration This is
Mareus, so it's good to fly or put it in immediately.
I'm
undertaking the mochi before that.
[Applause] I
just ignited it.
[Applause] Yeah,
I did the tail. I'm gonna eat this too.
It ’s 0 of. I ’ll make you do that with Smash Bros. x. Yeah, I ’m
nostalgic for the amount
.
-It's
dangerous and dangerous
Yes It's a round that is said to be a bit strong like a ban, but
this character was actually more scary.
I want to be a little stronger
Mapper I wonder when I'm leaving my job
I'm not over
I'm
still a little hopeful,
isn't it? I can't come when I blow the fire of the parts.
Next, I'm Count Dracula.
I have to put it on, but as you can
see,
a
boss on the building  It may be easier than jumping because there is a hit with mash, etc.
Here at Stone Bedding School
Let's stop
overdoing it.
If it's in, I'm totally fond of it and I'm bald. I have to be careful. I'm
impressed like a natural mountain
.
Gima Ogremon has to think carefully about how to fight. Why is it
shining? There is only a judgment here. No, there
is a judgment, but everyone else is invincible
. Let's go without
overdoing it.  It ’s
probably five times, it ’s
more dangerous.
It ’s
more dangerous. I do n’t know which one.
First of all, it's a bad one. It's
dangerous.
You can't do that kind of thing.
Anyway,
there's a grip on this one.
It looks like, but there are times when you can do it in a blink of an eye
.
This is also good.
Kuromon
seriously entered 9.9.
Yes, it's a master hand and a crazy hand.
Good
This is unusual from the beginning
Pyotta Oh
bad
6 I haven't given it on the screen, but the accumulated damage is already good I
can't sit
down
Kasadako has come out. It's
bad. This is bad.
Don't give up yet. I love you.
I
love
you. It's really cool. This is cool. This
is crazy.
I wonder if I can push it to the extent that it's a real thing
[Music
] Thank you for your hard
work.
I would be happy if you could.
Next is the introduction of the
songs. The list of songs is here.
9 new songs have been added, and the number of ff songs has become 11 songs.
4 of them are arranged and there is nothing to listen to.  It's arranged. It
will be added to these Midgar state pages
. Until now, there were only two ff songs
.  But that's not the case.
I'll say it in a loud voice.
After all, for example, when a character
collaborates in a game, there are many people who don't have a single song in
that
world.
You have to get permission so that there is no problem with everything.
Well, there are some that can be obtained properly by one company, but
all the rights are solved and implemented that it spans multiple companies or it is completely different depending on the country.  That's why I'm doing it,
so I'd like you to expand it to the fact that smartphones etc. are a little strange
.
Well, it's the important
delivery. It's scheduled to be delivered on December 23.
You can receive it as
it is. You can also buy it in the fleet.
By the way, adding a new character to Smash Bra every time is really a shop,
but since there are many fighters, it will be one of many on the fighter selection screen
.  I was wondering if
Sephiroth is a boss, so I wanted to spotlight the strength as a boss,
so I want you to see this
[Music]
What a special mode that appears for a limited time when you press fertilizer as a boss
If you can defeat this, you can use the large hollow stage with Sephiroth in advance
.
Easy normal will be decent, but very hard will be quite difficult.Actually, you
can clear the difficulty level you chose first.  If not, it's
always good to major in Sephiroth until it is officially released. It's always good for
those who chose Ferry Hard,
but I think it's too hearty, but I canceled it.
Delivery date of Sephiroth Challenge  Is scheduled from December 18th to December 23rd at
10 o'clock. Of course, if you don't buy Sephiroth, it won't be in the middle, so please be
careful.
[Music]
Various updates will be made on the 23rd of this distribution.
2p Cloud has been added with Super Research Takeshi Shinhazane Version 5, but this is also from the 23rd.
I thought it would be fun if possible, but I thought about the Sephiroth Challenge, but I implemented it.  I'm sorry
for the play
staff who took more time than I expected, but I
hope
that you can aim for a Lee Hard Clear with various fighters and various strategies if you can do it in a mode that has only appeared for the last
5 days.
I hope you enjoy the strength of Sephiroth as a boss. At the
end of the battlefield Ogawa state wash, you can now choose the correction method from all song lottery and my song select. All song lottery and song selection
from stage select are for all stage songs.
If you switch the menu with my song select, you will be drawn from the washing spiral my song select
[Music]
Also, I could not introduce it in the game, so
I put out a book of Sephiroth's victory screen  I would like to do this
[Applause]
[Music
] Masahiro I would like to finish the presentation, but I
really had a hard time recording this time.
Anyway, there was a problem with the equipment.
I think it wouldn't have been possible to deliver if this noise was mixed in at home when delivering at home
. It's important to be able to confirm that, so the staff are really tired, so
thank you very much.